james holden
should just follow you around don't
again
are you a cop
not anymore
hey guys pete here this is gonna be an
in-depth recap of season one of the
expanse that means there will be
spoilers if you haven't seen it and it's
a long one so let's just jump right into
things
season one opens with a mystery woman
alone floating in zero gravity inside a
small compartment on a ship no one
answers her calls for help and she's run
out of water eventually she's able to
force her way out and the ship she's on
looks deserted her name patch says julie
and her flight suit has the word scopuli
printed on the chest
she sees an sos message on a display
screen and makes her way to the
engineering bay inside she sees that
something mysterious is growing on the
reactor in the blue structure she sees a
human figure that looks like it's being
consumed by whatever this is and the
sequence ends with her screaming next we
visit ceres which is the largest object
in the asteroid belt between mars and
jupiter in the expanse's timeline it's
long been converted into a station
that's a vital port for the belt it has
millions of permanent residents and
tycho manufacturing was able to spin the
asteroid giving it an artificial gravity
of one-third g it's a hub of resource
extraction and you get an idea of what
life is like for people who live and
work there from an activist talking to a
crowd in a public space ceres was once
covered with ice enough to provide
drinking water for generations but that
was all removed when mars and earth
first arrived that means that the people
who live and work there now are
dependent on corporations for their
basic survival needs water and air are
rationed as a way to control the
population and make them compliant
policing in the belt is handled by
contractors who are there to protect the
interests of the inner planets and their
corporations you meet miller who's
employed by an earth-owned security
company he's a belter whose signature
hat adds to his worn out detective kind
of vibe we hear him referred to as a
well walla and when his partner asks he
explains that it means they view him as
a traitor to his people
following him around you learn a lot
about what kind of man he is and how
things work on series he's a heavy
drinker but he seems dedicated to his
job and he's somewhat cynical in that he
knows things are rigged and isn't above
making a little money taking a side cut
for himself as a result of that
situation
his partner at star helix is an earther
and that provides insight into relations
between inners and belters in their
earlier scenes you also see how
generations of living in low gravity
have changed belter's bodies and that
works to help otherize them as they're
visually distinct from people who grew
up on a planet with gravity the show
isn't really able to depict this with
every belter character all the time they
all basically look like humans in the
end but you are supposed to keep in mind
that people from the belt and to a
lesser extent people who grew up on mars
can be spotted and they are
discriminated against
miller's boss gives him a new assignment
to find the daughter of a wealthy
earther family he's supposed to find
this woman julie mal who left home and
relocated to the belt after getting
involved with the protest movement and
forced her to go home
due to the sensitive nature of what is
essentially a kidnap job miller is
supposed to look for her in his spare
time and keep things off the books
on earth you meet christian avasarala at
home with her family she's a master
politician and maneuverer who uses her
connections to get things done her
official post is the un deputy
undersecretary which isn't an elected
position so she has a lot of power but
she doesn't have the same accountability
as someone who has to sell themselves to
the public in order to win elections
it's worth noting that in the 24th
century the un is the government for the
entire planet the nation-states that we
know all ceded their sovereignty in the
face of climate disaster and ecological
collapse at the end of the 21st century
when avasarala learns that there's a
belter being held at a black site and
that he was caught smuggling stealth
technology you see that she's not above
using torture to try to get answers
earth's gravity's enough to make his
fragile belter body suffer just by
forcing him to stand under his own
weight
on board the pure and clean
corporation's ice hauler the canterbury
you meet the earther james holden
dishonorably discharged from the un navy
you get the idea that he doesn't want to
have a lot of extra responsibilities as
he turns down a promotion to become the
ship's executive officer the cant
receives a distress signal and captain
mcdowell decides not to answer it later
on his own holden decides to log it
after he enhances it and notices there's
a woman's voice saying please help me by
him doing this now they're obligated to
respond under law the ship flips and
burns and they find a wounded ship
called the scopuli which was the same
name we saw on the flight suit in the
opening sequence a shuttle crew is put
together to investigate holden naomi
nagata the chief engineer shed garvey
the med tech officer alex kamal who's a
pilot and a mechanic named amos burton
take the shuttle the night to take a
closer look they don't really find much
and they don't find any survivors and
they have to leave in a hurry when the
captain informs them a ship has popped
up in their vicinity it came out of
nowhere so they're presuming stealth
technology and alex points out that that
means it might be martian it fires
torpedoes which go right by their
shuttle towards the canterbury as they
approach holden is talking to his lover
at a and just as she tells him there's
something he should know the canterbury
and everyone on board is destroyed that
leaves the night out in the middle of
nowhere and this creates a situation
where you can pick up some important
information about the characters and the
challenges of surviving in space if
you're paying attention one thing to
keep in mind is that a job on an ice
hauler isn't a sought after position it
is the kind of job that'll take anyone
that's capable of doing it with no
questions asked it's the kind of place
where you end up because you don't have
any other better options or maybe you're
just someone who doesn't want to be
found in the first few episodes of the
show you learn bits and pieces of who
these characters are as they find
themselves in a desperate situation
where they're familiar they work
together but they don't know each other
well beyond amos and naomi holden he may
be reluctantly in charge here but he is
quick to act and maybe too quick at that
he was ready to chase after the stealth
ship alex he may not have been a top
pilot when he was in the navy but under
pressure you can see that he can fly he
got them through the debris field amos
seems to be extremely loyal at least to
naomi but he also doesn't seem put off
by using violence when necessary he has
a talk with holden when they go out to
fix the antenna where you can see that
he thinks a little bit differently naomi
is highly educated and resourceful and
the fact that she would probably be
qualified for a much better job makes
you wonder why she's there in the first
place in shed well we'll come back to
him in a minute in their struggle to
make it out alive the survivors of the
night discover that the beacon that
called them to the scopuli was martian
made that in the stealth tech lead them
to believe that mars may have been
behind the nuking of the canterbury and
when the mcrn warship the donager
answers their call for help they think
it's very possible that they're there to
finish the job they don't really have a
choice here their survival depends on
them being rescued and holden decides to
rush out a statement broadcast it to
everyone which in his mind will keep
them safe as they're being taken onto
the martian ship he identifies himself
that they're survivors from the
canterbury and even though he doesn't
say it directly everything about his
statement makes it sound like mars is
responsible for killing their ship
on series miller heads to investigate
julie's apartment after feeling the
effects of the water rationing in his
own shower at first he doesn't find out
much she finds out she was arguing with
her father back and forth and that he
was threatening to sell her racing penis
the razorback later at the docks he
finds her connection to the scopuli and
at the same time he notices that local
gangsters have been abandoning their
territory on ceres also holden's message
has gotten out and has created real
tension between the belt and mars that
eventually leads to riots as the
oppressed belters take out their
frustrations against inners on the
station including havlock who gets
attacked by locals miller continues to
pursue julie despite his boss telling
him to back off he meets anderson dawes
who's a mysterious leader of the outer
planets alliance the opa who claims he
has no connection with julie or the
scopuli
on the doninger the survivors from the
cant are being interrogated by
lieutenant lopez since they don't really
know each other he tries to turn them
against each other to get information
and plants the seeds that naomi is an
opa sleeper agent this starts to feel
more likely when another stealth ship
appears and starts to pursue the
martians the ship's captain thinks it's
there to rescue naomi
on earth we meet the un undersecretary
general sadavir aaronright who was
pissed when he found out that christian
was torturing the belter who she does
interview again in a humane environment
but she still doesn't get any answers
and as he's being transferred to the
moon he allows himself to be killed by
not taking the high g injections
avasarala then manipulates the un
ambassador to mars who is her old family
friend she gives him bogus intel then
watches how the martians react to it
she's able to deduce that they weren't
involved in destroying the cant when
they scramble to see if any of their
stealth tech is missing mars does figure
out that the ambassador was used by
christian and then they ban him from the
planet he cuts ties with her and then
later he dies in an apparent suicide
avasarala now knows that someone who
wants to start a war is responsible for
the cant and she tries to send the ship
to the doninger to rescue holden and the
others
on taiko station you meet fred johnson
who's overseeing the construction of a
generationship for the mormons you see
that he's a no-nonsense kind of guy when
there's talk of replacing him over his
connections to the opa you also learn
that he's watching the situation with
the doninger closely
there holden's taken to the bridge and
refuses to take back his statement and
blame naomi for the cant what they
thought was one ship following them
turns out to be several and those start
to attack firing torpedoes at first this
isn't concerning as the doninger is a
flagship of the most technologically
advanced navy in the system but to their
surprise their pdc cannons aren't nearly
as effective as they should be and they
realize the attackers have some advanced
weaponry of their own this leads to an
intense and brutal close quarter battle
with the doninger being boarded shed
winds up as one of the casualties as his
head is blown clean off by a round
passing through the ship things look
dark for naomi alex and amos whose
compartment is now running out of air
and surrounded by vacuum when holden
tells the captain that these ships are
similar to the one that destroyed the
cant she has lopez take him to put him
on a shuttle because he's the only
witness to both attacks they fight their
way out and on the way lopez finally
explains what happened on phoebe station
which was mentioned a couple of times
during the interrogations the donager
had gone there after the research
station went dark for several weeks they
found no survivors and a clear cover-up
but don't know who was behind it or why
holden breaks away to rescue the others
not wanting to leave them behind and
they all make it to the hangar bay where
they're able to make it through heavy
fire to board the tachi before the
captain scuttles the doninger the crew
watch itself destruct as they make it
out on the corvette class light frigate
miller gets another big clue after the
series riot when he recognizes a dead
guy from julie's dating profile he turns
out to be a data broker who was hiding
his true identity and this leads miller
to discover a flight path for a ship
called the anubis havelock's in the
hospital and he's gonna survive and when
miller goes there we get an idea of how
his situation is starting to wear on him
as he's starting to become consumed with
julie in her case anderson dawes comes
clean admitting that she was opa he's
looking forward to and he offers up
havelock's attacker in return for any
information that miller comes across
miller does pass on the chance of
getting revenge and instead goes and
finds a guy whose ship duly chartered in
the time when she was getting more
involved with the opa who gives him a
lead while he's following up on that he
notices a robotic hamster in the shop he
went to and was reminded of the one that
was in her apartment when he goes back
there he finds a data cube he hides that
in his hat and then when he goes outside
he's abducted in a series of flashbacks
we learn about how fred johnson became
known as the butcher of anderson station
during his time as a colonel in the un
marine corps the part he played in that
atrocity made him infamous and is a big
part of why he's in the belt trying to
improve conditions for belters and why
he got involved with the opa
he's offered the tachi and everyone on
board safe harbor at taiko station and
even though naomi is against the idea at
first they realize they don't have any
other options
they follow his instructions they're
able to change the transponder code and
when they have to rename it to finish
the process holden chooses the name
rosannante
on earth officerol is trying to get
access to a spy on tycho which aaron
wright eventually gives her there the
rosannante has arrived fred johnson
tells the crew he's happy to put them up
but he wants to use their ship when they
refuse to just hand it over he recruits
them for the mission he says that lionel
polanski is the only survivor from the
scopuli which is a ship that he
commissioned for an opa mission at this
point there's tension between the people
on the rossanante holden admitted that
he was the one who logged the distress
call that pissed everybody off and then
there were further issues when alex and
amos realized that naomi already knew
still there's really nowhere else for
anyone to go so they all get on board
for the plan
we revisit this character diogo who
miller busted but let go for stealing
water on ceres in an effort to go
straight he's taken a job with his uncle
mateo and you see another example of how
the martians make things difficult for
the belters whenever they get the chance
mateo loses it he drops the ogo out of
the airlock before he fights back he
goes out in the blaze of glory flinging
his now impounded hall into the martian
ship
after being abducted miller's getting a
beat down from anderson dawes and his
people because they want to know what he
knows about julie it gets personal when
miller brings up dawes's dead sister and
we hear the story about that and how
that's part of his inspiration for doing
what he does now the interaction
completely soured him on miller and his
lack of loyalty to the belt and he tells
his people to space him he's saved at
the last minute by his co-worker octavia
who kills dawes's guys before the
airlock opens
miller checks the data cube that he got
from julie's place and learns that
there's a bio weapon being developed on
phoebe based on that he comes up with
the theory that julie knew about the bio
weapon and took that information to
dawes he sent her to retrieve the weapon
for the opa because they think they
could buy the belter's independence with
it then she disappeared and he believes
it has something to do with the people
who are making the weapon and that they
also blew up the canterbury making it
look like mars did as a diversion to
draw any potential attention away from
them when he goes to work when he tells
his boss at star helix she just fires
him she locks him out of the system
takes away his credentials and he takes
that to mean that dawes got to her
before he came back none of this stops
miller though and in fact hitting the
slow spot just clarifies things he's
been obsessed with julie's case for a
while dawes implied that he was in love
with julie and don't forget he's never
met the girl and now it's to the point
where he sees this as the thing that
might be able to save him it's really
all he has left he gets a message from
his old friend sematimba who he asked to
look into the anubis he said that it
never arrived on eros but one of its
shuttles did and the anubis 1a is still
there miller decides to leave and you
see him cash in his bribes in the former
casino chips which are the only way to
pass money under the radar everything
else is digital and then he books
passage on a transport
avasarala goes to the family farm in
montana to try to learn about james
holden in this period of time it's not
easy to have children on earth because
of restrictions and holden has eight
parents who all contributed dna and
raised him as a collective she talks
with elise who carried and gave birth to
him and she convinces her that yeah he's
got issues but he's not some kind of
terrorist plotter christian has made
assurances to elise and is instantly
troubled to learn that aaron wright has
sent a black ops team to take hold and
out he has intel that they're traveling
to eros on a converted martian gunship
with fake transponder codes supplied by
the eopa through fred johnson their spy
kenzo snuck onto the ross ante but he
gets discovered when he's sending out a
transmission he proves helpful in a
run-in they have with a martian boarding
skiff but he's still a stowaway they
don't trust him and they lock him up
miller arrives on arrows he gets into
trouble right away roughing up the dock
master but then he reunites with his
childhood friend who works security on
the station he lets miller know that
lionel polanski is actually julie mal
and that she booked a room at the blue
falcon hotel right after she arrived on
the shuttle from the anubis
out in space the rossi crew finds that
ship and learned that it was headed to
arrows from phoebe station they search
it to discover that it's mostly empty
but they do recover a safe that they
can't get into so they take it with them
then they also find what julie found in
the reactor only now it's inactive that
changes though when amos restarts the
reactor and they decide to leave when
they see it start to come to life before
they leave they decide to nuke the
anubis and then they head to arrows
they also go looking for liona polanski
they do get attacked by that black ops
team that was sent there by aaron right
and during the gun battle miller arrives
and he's able to help them out he
recognizes holden but his only objective
there is to get to julie's room and
everyone else follows him upstairs there
they do find julie's body that looks
like it's being taken over by that same
thing that they saw on the anubis so in
the end miller was able to find julie
but he got there too late and at this
point there's nothing that anybody can
do
you get a flashback recounting how she
ended up in the blue falcon which miller
had mostly pieced together
you learned that the weapon was tied to
her father and that when they went after
it they were hoping to take it from a
non-military science vessel and in her
mind she was just trying to make sure it
wouldn't be used against belters
you see her journey and how everything
plays out right up to the point where
they find her from julie's point of view
and you see how the substance from the
anubis affected her because of the
shootout and the dead people downstairs
they have no choice but to leave her
behind and they run into sematimba in
the lobby he tells them to leave right
away and that he'll try to cover up
their involvement they do leave but
before he even gets started anthony
dresden arrives looking for julie and
basically says he's sematimba's boss
because the security agency works for
him he goes upstairs takes samples from
julie saying that the substance isn't
airborne but he tells his associate not
to touch it if it's wet he also tells
them that julie's body contains more
than enough and to prepare the
injections
he then contacts julie's father jul
pierre mao explaining that his daughter
is dead but hey it's not all that bad
because now they have a replacement
sample of what he refers to as
protomolecule for the first time
joule is upset but he tells dresden to
proceed as planned
holton and the crew are trying to get
back to the ross ante but alarms starts
sounding announcing a radiation breach
and everything starts to get shut down
miller thinks that this is too much of a
coincidence and that everything must be
connected and goes to investigate holden
decides to go with him and tells naomi
to leave with the ship if they don't
make it back in three hours the security
forces are giving everyone injections
that they claim are to protect them from
the radiation exposure miller sees
dresden which he recognizes from the
footage from phoebe's station and tries
to shoot him holden intervenes and
dresden gets away on a shuttle after
interrogating a security officer they
start to put things together now miller
knows where all the gangsters from
series went to they all got jobs working
on eros mostly installing cameras and
science equipment they gain access to
one of the shelters only to find people
collapsed in pain on the floor and then
they get hit with a huge dose of
radiation this is a death sentence if
they can't make it back to the ship's
med bay in time they only have a couple
of hours until they'll expire
elsewhere avasarala finds evidence of
advanced fusion drives like the ones on
the anubis fred johnson has cracked the
data cube he recovered from lopez and
broadcast that the attack on the donager
was carried out by advanced stealth
ships that were built on earth aaron
wright confirms this but tells christian
they were for private contractors not
the un military she's starting to put it
together that aaron wright might be
connected to everything that's happening
including the destruction of the
canterbury she knows that she'll have to
be careful if that's the case and she
sends her family away while playing a
part to deceive aaron wright alex amos
and naomi make it back to the rossi with
some attimba when they decide to wait
for holden he objects and he tries to
take over until amos ends up shooting
him this is another example of his
loyalty to naomi and how violence
doesn't really faze him holden and
miller have a harrowing journey through
eros and on the way they realize that
all of what's happening is a planned
experiment with the help of the security
force protogen is infecting everyone
with the bio weapon from phoebe and
letting it spread just to observe what
will happen they eventually fight their
way back to the ship miller gets a
chance to kill the belter who impaled
havelock and after causing a riot
they're able to make it back to the
airlock of the rossi
inside they get treatment for their
radiation exposure and alex is able to
free the ship from the clamps by
shedding its gas hauler disguise the
season ends with the spy kenzo who
holden left behind walking around eros
looking at this transformation you see
that the bio weapon or proto-molecule is
pretty much taking over the station as
he comes across the particularly large
growth which looks somewhat organic but
mechanical at the same time you see him
get grabbed and pulled into it and while
it's not really clear what's happening
nothing about it seems good
in the end a string of incidents have
brought this core group of characters
together as the crew of the rasanante as
the only witnesses to what really
happened they become rather important
and the safe they took with them from
the anubis is set up to be a crucial
piece of understanding what happened on
phoebe miller's investigation put
together most of the pieces in relation
to julie's part in the big picture and
in his pursuit of that he's found
himself with no place to go he's now
connected with the rossi but will
certainly have some feelings about the
death of his friend samutimba plus it's
really not clear where his head will be
after getting so involved with julie's
story and making things personal in that
regard if the thought of finding julie
was slowing a spiral where does he go
from here they'll all need to rely on
fred johnson and the opa and he's just
released information that seems to
incriminate earth in the same way that
holden's message about the cant
implicated mars avasarala is in a unique
position on earth where she has
perspective on what's really happening
but she'll have to outmaneuver aaron
wright and his new security advisor jul
pierre mao he was involved in the plan
to experiment with the proto-molecule
after protogen's discoveries on phoebe
and that came at the cost of feeding a
lot of belter lives to it on eros just
to see what it might do
since this is a dense season with a lot
of world building delivered through the
character development i'm gonna leave it
there for now i'll try to follow this up
with a more detailed explanation about
the ending and what it all means let me
know what you thought about season one
of the expanse in the comments and let
me know if you have any questions please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon